- Good Morning, Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the
world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is fall forward.
Over to you, Denzel Washington.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- I've found that nothing in life
is worthwhile unless you take risks.
Nothing.
Nelson Mandela said, "There
is no passion to be found
"playing small and
settling for a life that's
"less than the one you're
capable of living."
Now, I'm sure in your
experiences in school
and applying to college
and picking your major
and deciding what you
want to do with life,
I'm sure people have told you to make sure
you have something to fall back on,
make sure you got something
to fall back on, honey.
But I never understood that concept,
having something to fall back on.
If I'm going to fall,
I don't want to fall back on anything
except my faith.
I want to fall forward.
I figure at least this way
I'll see what I'm going to hit.
Fall forward.
This is what I mean.
Reggie Jackson struck out
2,600 times in his career,
the most in the history of baseball,
but you don't hear about the strike outs.
People remember the home runs.
Fall forward.
Thomas Edison conducted
1,000 failed experiments.
Did you know that? I didn't know that.
Because the one thousand and
first was the light bulb.
Fall forward.
Every failed experiment is
one step closer to success.
- So I love the concept of falling forward
and seeing failures not as true failures
but as opportunities to learn
and grow and get better.
I think it also applies
to how we see ourselves
in our daily lives and
the decisions we make
and how hard we are on ourselves.
I believe that you need
to kick yourself forward
instead of kicking yourself down.
I once got asked in an interview
by the reporter who was saying,
"How hard should you be on yourself?
"Can you be too hard on yourself?"
And at first I was
confused by the question.
Too hard on yourself, how can
you be too hard on yourself?
No, you can't be too hard on yourself.
And after going home
and thinking about it,
I was actually frustrated with my answer
because I'm so in on the
hard on myself forward
and kicking myself forward
that the part that I missed
was most people kick themselves down.
Most people are so hard on themselves
that then they don't take any action,
that they tell themselves
they can't do something,
that they suck and they'll
never amount to anything,
and they have no value,
and they should quit
and go off and do something else.
Those people just kick themselves down,
where what you want is the
ability to kick yourself forward,
to say, "This sucked,
I know I can do better.
"What I just created is not my best work.
"Here are the 20 areas
that I need to improve on,
"and I'm going to go and
work on that right now."
To see the failure and the
negativity and the holes
in what you're making and use that
as motivation to go off and do better.
That's how I default to, I think it's how
most entrepreneurs will default
to, you kind of have to.
If you just live in negativity land
of how much you suck and
how you're never going to
get anywhere, you're just
kicking yourself down,
it's really hard to build
a successful business.
If you are that hard on yourself
and you never take any action,
you're never going to get anywhere.
But entrepreneurs who
are hard on themselves,
that kick themselves forward,
they could be harder on themselves
than anybody else around them
but in a positive way that
pushes them to action,
those are the people who win.
So, I encourage you to think about
you being hard on yourself.
Is it helping you?
Are you just beating yourself up
or are you using it as motivation
and fuel to do a better job?
So I'm going to make that
the question of the day.
Question of the day: Do
you kick yourself down,
or do you kick yourself forward?
Super curious, leave it
in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Jean from 3rdeye Brand.
Jean, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word,
and posting that picture on Instagram.
I really, really, really appreciate it,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
(keys typing)
- And as you begin to challenge yourself,
you'll discover some things about yourself
that you don't know right now.
The other thing is you
begin to look at yourself,
look at your dreams and
begin again to experiment
and stepping into your greatness.
One of the things that's very important,
whatever goals and dreams that you have,
repeat after me please: Make
your move before you're ready.
- [Audience] Make your
move before you're ready.
Yeah, Price Pritchett, who's
a great great motivator
and trainer, he said, "Make
your move before you're ready."
We're instructed in life to
walk by faith and not by sight.
See, you want to really
begin to stretch yourself.
You want to become a risk taker.
You want to raise the bar on yourself.
Most people won't do that.
See, most people engage in
low-life living, low-risk living.
This God said, "If you're
not willing to risk,
"you cannot grow, and if you cannot grow,
"you cannot become your best,
"and if you cannot become
your best, you can't be happy,
"and if you can't be happy,
then what else is there?"
I like what Helen Keller said,
"Life is short and unpredictable,
eat the dessert first."
(audience laughing)
And so you want to begin
to take some chances.
You want to begin to challenge yourself
and make it okay to fail and
learn from your failures.
Don't allow
fear
of failure
and the allure, the attractiveness,
of playing it safe in life to draw you in.
You can't get out of life alive,
you got to die to leave here.
- The movies that I
made while I was making
The Fresh Prince, so it
was The Fresh Prince during
the winter, and then the
summers were Bad Boys,
Independence Day, Men in Black, you know.
So it really captured a time.
So it's very difficult.
I wouldn't have it any other way, I love
being able to make people
smile and cheer over that,
but I also am going to
boldly go to new creation.
Even something like the decision,
I had the two screen plays in front of me
for the Independence Day
2, and for Suicide Squad,
so I had to choose
between the two of those.
And even the choice of
going to Suicide Squad,
nothing about the qualities of the movies,
but the choice of trying to go forward
versus clinging and clawing backwards.
I do want to aggressively go forward
and do new things and
create, and hopefully
be able to stumble upon a new heyday.
- Failure is a part of the
learning process, right?
What's the risk of failure?
What, you'll be embarrassed
or risk of failure?
How do you distinguish failure
from learning in your whole life?
Failure implies that it's
stopped, that the game stops.
If it's part of your
failing and then you learn,
then that learning is part
of the moving forward, right?
So that is what the process is like:
fail, learn, move forward.
And constantly do that,
because you're cutting edge,
you're going where people
haven't been before,
and inventiveness, that's exciting.